and for watching like for trailers and
then finally see in the movie I finally
know how to pronounce this movie's name
Maleficent when I first saw the trailer
for this movie I thought it was
pronounced male ficient which sounds
like a Viagra by the way the best kind
of Viagra the dining gets you hard I
don't know then I saw all these trailers
and none of them hooked me but this is
the first time in a while where I truly
delightfully surprised make me feel like
a little kid again I love this movie it
was cute Simpson had him like a major
fantasy element - it was dark but
beautiful to look at like Jada Pinkett
Smith Oh black Jews yeah you mean
audience for this film are children but
I honestly felt like they didn't meet
her in a kid's film like a real film for
families film it's cheesy but fun and
that moves you surprises you an overall
is this fast-paced fantasy escapism the
movie moves fast but its pacing is
perfect
first off Angelina Jolie she made this
movie everyone who watches this show
knows I'm gonna talk about lying to bang
her I still do like even with the horns
I'm I will masturbate to death tonight I
was surprised by how committed all these
actors were like I can only imagine here
what the film is is a live-action Disney
film you'd expect a lot of actors to
probably not take it too seriously but
they were all very committed but
especially her t and act like in Disney
movie so we don't chimney all with all
will she just really played the part
even in the cheesy character orange
speech that you see coming I found
myself wanting to cry I wanted to you as
I said Veronica who just wouldn't shut
the [ __ ] up like she didn't talk a lot
but when she cries like loudly
obnoxiously
really want to have sex with her too so
I endured the tears Veronica you're
watching what's that baby as I'm Mexican
vagina treating you yeah but my mother
cut you really love her you care for her
the way they intertwined her storyline
with the Sleeping Beauty storyline was
great it wasn't like a Sleeping Beauty
story and then there was what was going
on Maleficent the whole time like it's
quite a while before they actually get
to the Sleeping Beauty story but
everything before that was just as if
not more captivating back to Jolie with
the Wayne's man now he's so [ __ ] hot
I just wanna be [ __ ] her and then
read for about to come you know she
spots her wings up in the air and then
we just started flying in and I'm
[ __ ] her and she does that little
spin twirl then she loses you know group
of me and then she has to fly down and
save my ass and then when we fly we
almost crash but then we both allowed on
the grass to me yeah it'd be like the
most ultimate yet most terrifying orgasm
kids if you're watching continue
watching okay no seriously she's like
I'm not talking a lot about her but she
is like the main reason to watch this
move tears are very much emotionally a
layered character it brings the right
amount of humor to the rule humour
comedy the gift of all comedians I have
that comedy in there that makes your
[ __ ] more interesting to watch like but
that's another thing about this movie
like it's not a comedy but it has some
truly funny moments I never like cracked
up or broke out hysterically like when
Russell Crowe saying in laymen's or up
jokes about Russell Crowe Steen Mike
[ __ ] are still really funny sharlto
copley had no idea this dude was in the
film he's that guy from district 9 in
Elysium in Casey Anthony no did to the
villain in this movie and it was another
performance from like this is a really
committed actor right now it was
fantastic man like I don't want to give
away too much about whose character is
but he's a very well portrayed
antagonist like when he starts losing it
[ __ ] you're like that dudes losing his
[ __ ] he's just like tire winging out of
his life does it suck when you have
diarrhea diarrhea is like the worst
thing like you never want to tell people
you have diarrhea you can be really ill
the serious case the watery shit's you
never want to tell some because you know
they're just gonna [ __ ] it
laughing you buy you have diarrhea
enough to keep on [ __ ] it sucks
anyway guys we're getting off track
there are children watching this review
this is a house of God
okay so they did Alice in Wonderland
which was silly but kind of like a movie
okay look I know this one's based off
like the actual story not the Disney
movie but still it counts they did Snow
White and the Huntsman but that was like
a serious yet overall very boring film
why that was a snoozefest
boom ex-girlfriend who is no one we were
you ruined us now we got Maleficent
which actually has the right balance of
humor and drama Oh bro it's just very
entertaining at times it's very moving
like there's a lot of movies where you
expect there to be great visual effects
I wasn't expecting much out of this but
I was watching I'm like these are some
really awesome visual effects I loved
some of the action scenes and exploring
like the the fairy world or whatever
that wasn't not home off of a comment by
the way if you were thinking I mean
there were moments where they actually
Jolie it's like using her wings to like
just shush people away or than like
slicing people blocking stuff you know
it's like these are the most flamboyant
wings I've ever seen anyone ever has oh
I can fly look at me now so hi sky oh
yes
[ __ ] me Ryan apparently I am I'm not
imagining Angelina Jolie anymore I am
imagining [ __ ] a homosexual fairy
that really sounds homophobic oh she's
not an angel I can't say that I'm not
home I've let a guy suck my dick before
how was that for you children out there
she has like a number two like a helper
minion who was originally a bird but she
turned it to a human and now she can
interact with this guy and then she
could turn him as all kinds of animals
last one she turns him into I was like
dude [ __ ] sweet you know like a lot
of people are into this movie and I
thought yo like I'm liking this movie
but I don't want to like it right now I
know I want to be one of the
narcissistic people but that last one
she turned to me too you know but I was
like okay hands down that is [ __ ]
sweet CinemaScore even an A rating
Rotten Tomatoes hasn't like a 52% this
movies definitely more for an audience
because it's just
Phantasy escaping heartwarming
entertainment let me get straight to the
point here all I gotta say well
obviously got a Ryan super heartwarming
right
alright guys they should check them out
a review for Maleficent won't you go
ahead school that call me box below and
tell me would you masturbate to Angelina
Jolie with the horns and I still don't
quite know how to put annotations
actually link it to these sites I
thought I did but I'm just gonna talk
about it follow me on Twitter if all the
real rejects on Twitter
do you follow their Facebook you could
follow them on Instagram and I can
follow them on vine god worked
everywhere it's hard being a youtuber
last but not least you finally get
updated every time one of my reviews or
videos is out going to clear this but
about my dig to subscribe that's right
dig let me say something out this little
Maleficent yes [ __ ] all kinds of
fairies oh no that goddamn word man I
that word has become a disgrace in
society shame on people for changing
that word to make people like me look
like an idiot
cuz no I was making a joke about like
the children's kind of fairy
dude this is just not going down the
path i watch it go down right now